ma la gente e benvenuti a un nuovo video
io sono fatti j
e oggi giochiamo al gioco delle ruote
felici siamo su è più questa ragazzi
allora in realtà la cosa che stavo
pensando e che siccome è il 113 e al 113
no è il 100 donne non so manco contare
l'episodio fanta i ragazzi era mente da
quando abbiamo superato il centesimo non
riesco neanche più a ricordarmi ma serio
e non riesco a ricordarmi che pisodio
siamo cioè ogni volta un capisco castle
che è merda perché c'è da me lo zio ma
perché tanto devo iniziare sempre i
livelli di è più esposti cazzo di di
arpioni inutili poi il livello e se
fruga perfetto yo yo secondo me c'era
un'ottima possibilità di crearci in quel
punto d'accesso ci avevo veramente io
conoscendo mi sarei morto solo un
arpione zio veramente perché tutti i
livelli con gli arpioni ne ha sparati
6.000 prove e fammi passare cazzo allora
ok per niente come non detto
yes mi è piaciuto il salto finale
[Musica]
per adesso il paradiso dei troll mi
sembra bello dal nome anche perché no
vabbè sta cosa era bellissima fuori a
sei andato dalla parte del sito alessio
che non ha
apri e vabbè adesso è stronzo a sei
andato dalla parte sbagliata significa
che domanda sei già dietro a ok
ero annoiato thanks for play no a ok mi
capisce sta funzionando sul serio mi sta
prendendo per il culo sul serio cioè
della serie guerra pensa lavoro capita
però quella che eri annoiato non l'avevo
capito pensavo fosse finito a livello
sul serio this is the elevator staind ma
la cover se nel mezzo era a dovevo
andare di sotto sul serio ho capito mi
sta crollando di continuo e sta
funzionando c'è la cosa divertente visti
livelli è che pur sapendo che sono delle
prese per il culo io non mi faccio
[ __ ] uguale
ok this way tutto io sto cadendo a pezzi
nei fatti non era da questa parte
dall'altra mi fate uscire per favore che
cio l'ansia qualcosa mi dice che non ho
vinto sul serio prove tolle dove non
avevo dubbi credimi perché c'è una mano
incastrata nella sedia troll e di nuova
e basta
ok bene mi stava andando in pappa il
cervello che già non penso io di mio
perché sono stupido ci manca solo quello
elevator simulator
ma come normal che ci ha difficoltà per
un cazzo di ascensore istruzioni blu è
sì sì sì certo non leggo un cazzo ma io
so giocare visto ma a un certo punto
iniziano a sparare armonia caso devo
andare nei rossi non ho capito bene non
c'e la voglia di leggere ragazzi
chi è il figlio di [ __ ] imposti lo
facciamo in porzione è la madonna ha
imposti con nel senso che hanno aggiunto
le barriere wow sono più prove in questo
che in quello di prima regala ma come
come già sto facendo
cazzo sono già fatta porca [ __ ] le 18
di sotto di sotto e [ __ ] scassati
sono incastrato merda come effetto vai
vai vai myslovice zio dove stiamo
andando sul cazzo affanculo solivo sono
vivo veloce bye bye bye bye bye quanto
ce n'è ancora non credo di poter
resistere ancora per molto però eh vabbè
ho fatto ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta e
cazzo lo vivo e affanculo sono gravi ma
non ci credo mai pur ci credo mai ma
quanto dura suo livello minchia maraga è
un ora che sto andando giù ancora son
vivo come è possibile
eccole qua o dio non ci credo ho vinto
l'impossible ma va ma non è possibile
cioè non ce l'ho fatta a vincere il
normale ho vinto limpopo di renderlo
faresti ben dipende cioè mica mi chiedi
di girare nudo per casa che farei anche
quello voglio rugby demo senso allora
vorresti essere il miglior uomo al mondo
ma anzi vuol dire migliore che cazzo
vuol dire vorrei saper parlare inglese
aprirà il più bel uomo al momento sono
già chi bell'uomo non è più stupido uomo
al mondo quello sono perfetto quindi mi
descrive oppure più intelligente ma di
brutto beh ma io so che la [ __ ] la posso
anche conquistare colpi greco quindi
andiamo con certo 70 per cento proprio
convinto che 70 per cento delle persone
abbiano scelto web lo faresti avere un
solo capezzolo o avere tre che a prezzo
di quale delle due ma contro i capezzoli
unisci i puntini alla fine più figo tra
i capezzoli vorresti saper volare o
correre veloce e saltare
volare ma sei scemo vorresti morire come
un astronauta nello spazio o morire come
un soldato in battaglia stranota nello
spazio e l'avranno scelta al 90 x 180 x
155 veramente vorresti sapere respirare
sott'acqua o parlare agli animali
parlare agli animali tutta la vita
bellissimo mi è piaciuto di più dei
render quelli che facciamo una volta
beni basketball premo queste ragazzi che
[Musica]
cazzo che ho fatto ma carai figlia
figlia forza ti lancio io ti lanciato ma
non ci sono riuscito ma dai ma mi chiama
che mira a taiz porgeva che canestro che
cadesse roma pratiche non è entrato no
voglio vedere replay è bellissimo o
inchiodato da fantastico questo è stato
stupendo rafting 1
devo provare è la madonna che se no vi
prego questi no li odio ci ho messo una
vita l'ultima volta la fast i livelli
quando vedevi lanciare tula mi scappava
scusate eh va bene e vai vai vai veloce
meglio però c'è un effetto strano stesse
corde c'hanno don't greg va bene non
gravo don't greg batman ei club c'è uno
dei due puoi farlo
don't crebbe un cazzo però perso una
gamba e ragazzi devo scendere veloce
adesso grappa di roba forte come simoni
granbassi purchè ma come ho fatto a
finire sui mazzette
non ci credo porca eva cosa sto facendo
stanno saltando tutto il livello senza
volerlo va bene ciao nonno ti va di fare
le cose sporche io e te
bye bye bye bye bye bye qua perfetto ce
l'ha fatta
per una volta nella vita ho centrato il
buco che perfetto vai vai vai veloce
veloce veloce è stato figo però era
fatto bene rispetto ai live you be rock
swing che io abbia mai fatto negli
ultimi tempi al man salva la terra che
cazzo è successo edi è la tua posizione
di salvataggio quella state calmi cazzo
è va bene ma che cosa stai facendo manco
fossi io il problema ti salvo io mi
spiace zio non volevo asti bastardi o il
pozzo di the ring entra veloce forte io
mi sono solo legate una gamba nove
avevano capitolati ma io io io devo
salvare la terra 12 salva la terra e
perché allora gli abitanti della terra
mi attaccano che cazzo vogliono non
riesca a passare che avevo prende la
rincorsa affanculo va sasso inutile
perfetto ragazzi siamo mica anche il
seggiolino ci si mette mi fate uscire
che cadono bybee ci salva la terra cosa
devo fare qui devo buttarmi in acqua
c'era la bici che va sull'acqua e la
bici di gesù non ho capito il senso va
bene perché la gente deve urlare isto
livello
gli alieni ragazzi le bici saranno la
nuova arma alla distruzione non c'è
sappiatelo
hai salvato la terra si fa chi è grande
e grave come cazzo ti chiami il padre
pio che che serve alla terra con una
bici va bene più 18 uomini basta di
frascati un secondo l'idea il tuo
fratello ti odia io non ho un fratello
deficiente
ok ma video venivo invitato a devo fare
gli smart pro per rinfrescarmi il
secondo le idee perché non capisco che
cosa sto facendo la mia vita ogni volta
che gioca a tennis o salento il suo
dubbio esistenziale
una storia romantica va bene cos'è bella
molto romantica che cazzo di storia
romantica è questa spiegamento o dio
bisogna dire una storia romantica che si
desiderano limonata ma perché non ho
capito il senso ma va bene lo segnala la
tizia minchia che gol è una storia
romantica tra me la traversa che bella
porta slither io e il scape devo
scappare cosa cazzo c'entra questo
livello con slither io spiega beh certo
perché hai messo un [ __ ] verme per
quale motivo hai chiamato questo livello
si liberino
quale ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo ed
avervi ixtreme ixtreme live la caduta
estrema ci sono spaccate uno stinco
almeno perché devo provare a prendergli
il pube gli ho preso il pube avrà fatto
malissimo per os x attimo che non vedo
sangue finchè non vedo sangue non sono
soddisfatto ragazzi come si sta facendo
malissimo quello davanti
va bene che ti ho detto pupa melo ma non
intendevo nel vero senso della parola
chi sa quanto ti faccio male e va premi
i cali sono entrato nel collo come fa
non esserci sangue e staccati la testa e
va beh senti zio
ci sono dei problemi qui e io non sono
il tuo tappeto ci siamo chiariti non ne
vuole sapere sto tizio di sanguinare
ragazzi quindi amen
pazienza davide vi sia piaciuto conclude
l'episodio ragazzi consenso chiuda
sull'argomento è un bel like anche a
pagina di facebook e come ridotto tale
descrizione sei riuscita a far
sanguinare sto cristiano basta mi sono
rotto non ci riescono impedito oggi sono
impedito forte sangue sono orgoglioso di
me stesso sensore city siete lì ci
vediamo il prossimo vinto dai ragazzi